as of a few decades ago president-elect
Donald had received two classified
intelligence briefings since his
surprise election victory earlier this
month and the initial reaction is oh wow
this guy is being trusted with sensitive
information that's horrible that's a
correct reaction but after that your
second reaction should be wait a second
three weeks as president-elect and only
two of these intelligence briefings that
sounds sort of strange and it is current
and former US officials said that this
is by far a lower frequency than any
prior presidents elect with regard to
these classified intelligence briefings
a senior US official who receives the
same briefing delivered to President
Obama every day said that if Donald
Trump were to put a little time into
receiving these briefings it might help
him to get up to speed on what's going
on in the world and we know Trump needs
as much time as he can get to get up to
speed on world events his silly and
uninformed comments during the campaign
revealed that the guy is generally
clueless about most of these issues and
he needs to know about what's going on
in terms of security this is by the way
insights from all 16 US intelligence
agencies he needs to know what's going
on if he's going to be able to make
informed decisions about these issues
when he becomes president of the United
States this is major major stuff
containing some of the most guarded
secrets that the government is aware of
period and among other issues it relates
to Isis it relates to Syria this is
stuff that is useful for the president
to know and I've said it before and I'll
say it again there are political
disagreements that we might have with an
elected official a politician a
candidate but then there are systemic
problems conflicts of interest and using
the presidency to create a real world
kleptocracy through padding your pockets
with real estate deals that should go
beyond political issues and that's an
issue with Donald Trump simply not being
briefed about the things that the
president should know that goes beyond
politics or at least it should and
remember that article from Tony Schwartz
Tony Schwartz is the guy who
ghostwrote Trump's favorite or second
favorite book along with the Bible art
of the deal and Tony Schwartz said
listen Donald Trump has no attention
span I would be shocked if Donald Trump
read an entire book in the last 40 years
the TV is always on in the background
for Trump and if anything happens he
gets distracted like a bird when a shiny
piece of tinsel goes by in the
background the guy has no attention span
or ability to really focus I believe
that that's what President Obama was
referring to when he said at some point
after his meeting with president-elect
Donald he is in unpair of reason but he
is very quickly going to figure out that
there are some major demands here and
what is required of people in this
position and it's abundantly clear from
how we saw Trump behave during the
presidential campaign that he really
doesn't have much of an attention span
and and the idea that he is going to be
temperamental II unable to focus in for
30 minutes 60 minutes an hour and a half
on very detailed policy issues many of
which relate to national security that
is very very disturbing it's it's the
choice between and and I should go
further Mike Pence has been receiving
regularly the daily briefings and there
are those who are suggesting that this
hints at what we've already suspected
which is Trump will be sort of a
figurehead who is thirsty for the power
of the presidency but vice president
elect Mike Pence is actually going to be
running day-to-day operations and that's
no victory for progressives because it's
sort of the choice between
the clueless buffoon making the calls or
the dangerous religious right ideologue
who wanted funeral services for
miscarried fetuses in the state of
Indiana this is not exactly a good
choice and I've argued and I'd continue
to argue that actually Mike Pence would
be far more dangerous than would Donald
Trump
his his religious right ideologue sort
of demagoguery that is part and parcel
with that movement versus the uninformed
cluelessness of Donald Trump